quand tu dis trois douches par semaine
moi je l'ai eu ça c'était même pas à toi
douche par semaine c'était une douche
par semaine on l'a eu il fallait se
laver à l'eau froide à l'intérieur on
avait des toilettes avec un tuyau qui
coulait pour se laver ça veut dire que
c'est horrible c'est la prison la plus
horrible aujourd'hui dans toutes les
prisons il y a des douches dans la
cellule d'accord
alors ouais je vais t'appeler là je veux
bosser t'inquiète pas on nous écoute
de toute façon il marche pas les
téléphones qui sont ils sont tous cassés
utile puisque les nouvelles prisons ont
mis en place dans la cellule à la fois
la douche et à la fois le téléphone et
là l'objet ce dossier c'est de dire il
voulait plus que trois douches
un écran plasma téléphone
il mangeait
quoi c'est-à-dire un jour vous leviez le
matin vous voyez j'ai envie de manger
pâtes aux merguez c'est pas ton merguez
et ben je me faisais des pâtes au
merguez des pâtes au saumon je suis très
compliqué comme vous le faisiez vous je
les faisais moi non je les faisais
rentrer ah ouais ben tu veux que je
fasse la cuisine moi je fais même pas
casser un œuf d'accord
prends prends par exemple Genève j'étais
en prison à Genève tu commandes et on te
lis par comment ça s'appelle les goût
manivelo le truc là on te livre
réellement sur place ici en France il y
a pas ça mais en France tu te démerdes
autrement d'accord c'est c'est la jungle
que tu dois vivre mais la corruption
existe partout madame l'avocate existe
partout chez vous chez les politiciens
chez n'importe qui elle existe du moment
que tu as la somme tout se paye dans sa
vie dans la vie et quoi qu'il arrive il
y a des sommes qu'on ne refuse pas enfin
vous allez de prison vous les avez
faites et vous avez pu payer personne
pour pas les faire
d'accord mais non je vais te le dire
parce que tu me fais sortir de mes Gong
si la droite je serai resté au pouvoir
j'aurais pas été en prison parce que
c'est la gauche qui est passé c'est pour
ça que j'étais en prison et n'oublie pas
que le bordel que j'ai fait
s'il m'amène pas en prison qu'est-ce qui
se passe après c'est un cirque tu as vu
le bordel que j'ai fait avant d'aller en
prison et avant d'aller être sur enquête
j'ai fait un bordel je me suis fait
remarquer comme jamais si c'est quoi de
dépenser de 300 millions d'euros en 5
ans le bordel
vous fassiez pas un jour de prison parce
que pour moi infraction financière
réponse financière au final vous avez
fait X années de prison qui ont coûté de
l'argent à la société l'argent à jamais
été récupéré et ça a servi à quoi bah
pas grand chose
remboursé voilà parce que je ne vois pas
l'utilité de mettre les gens en prison
pour des infractions financières ça ça
c'est ce que je passe
quelque chose vous allez en prison je
veux te dire une vraie exclusivité et là
je vais te la donner devant tout le
monde je la donne pour toi Cyril moi
j'ai l'argent pour rembourser l'état
alors si en plus vous allez en prison
tu vas me laisser parler
pour rembourser mais j'ai un problème
j'ai ils m'ont à peu près pris pour 52
millions d'affaires et d'appartements et
de monter tout ça ils veulent pas me
déduire donc là est-ce que je paye ou je
paye pas m'a demandé à votre avis
un nouvel avocat la semaine dernière
je paye ma dette parce que j'ai donné de
l'honneur et du respect
moi j'aurais préféré que vous payer ce
que vous avez pris dis-moi que vous
n'allez pas en prison dis-moi que je
garde l'oseille je le garde pas juge
dites maintenant
en revanche vous pouvez pas dire que du
coup vous avez entièrement payé vos
dettes à la société moi j'ai payé
pour que je t'ai pris la TVA
j'ai fabriqué de la TVA je n'ai pas pris
pour arriver à payer donc
et moi je vais pas demander que j'allais
en prison
mais quand tu récupères à plus rien non
mais ce qu'elle veut que tu ailles en
prison
il est malade mais c'est nous qui payons
les prisons toi
[Applaudissements]